♪ ♪
>> I'VE BEEN SPEAKING WITH
GENERAL MATTERS.
WE'LL BE DOING THINGS
MILITARILY.
UNTIL WE CAN HAVE A WALL AND
PROPER SECURITY, WILL BE
GUARDING OUR BORDER WITH THE
MILITARY.
WE HAVE HORRIBLE, HORRIBLE, AND
VERY UNSAFE LAWS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
HOPEFULLY SOON, HOPEFULLY
CONGRESS WILL GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER AND GET AND CREATES A
VERY POWERFUL LAWS, LIKE MEXICO
HAS AND LIKE CANADA HAS AND
ALMOST ALL COUNTRIES HAVE.
WE DON'T HAVE LAWS.
WE HAVE CATCH AND RELEASE.
WE WILL BE DOING THINGS WITH
MEXICO AND THEY HAVE TO DO IT
OTHERWISE ARE NOT GOING TO DO
THE NAFTA DEAL.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT TALKING
ABOUT IMMIGRATION, TALKING ABOUT
NAFTA, TALKING ABOUT HOW HE'S
GOING TO SHORE UP THE SOUTHERN
BORDER WITH THE U.S. MILITARY.
NOW THE MEXICAN AMBASSADOR TO
THE U.S., WHO WE HAD ON
"SPECIAL REPORT" LAST NIGHT, AS
ASKING FOR AN OFFICIAL
CLARIFICATION FROM THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT ON EXACTLY WHAT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
MATTHEW CONTINETTI, EDITOR IN
CHIEF OF THE "WASHINGTON
FREE BEACON."
MARA LIASSON, NATIONAL POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT OF NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO CREATED KATIE PAVLICH,
NEWS EDITOR AT TownHall.com.
OKAY, MARA, PRESIDENT WAS ON A
TOY TEAR, TWEETING AND TALKING.
THE NEWS CONFERENCE AND AT THE
CABINET ROOM.
A LOT OF ABOUT THE U.S. MILITARY
ALONG THE BORDER.
>> YEP.
THIS IS A DRAMATIC, TOUGH ACTION
THAT HE CAN SEND A MESSAGE, YES,
I'M DOING SOMETHING ABOUT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, EVEN THOUGH
I COULDN'T GET FUNDING FOR MY
WALL IN THE OMNIBUS.
THAT IS A CONTEXT FOR THIS, HE'S
VERY FRUSTRATED ABOUT THAT AND
HE'S GOTTEN SUPPORT MIKE PUSHED
BACK FROM THE BASE BECAUSE OF
THAT.
THIS HAS BEEN DONE BEFORE.
GEORGE W. BUSH AND BARACK OBAMA
USE THE NATIONAL GUARD TO
SUPPLEMENT BORDER PATROL AGENTS
WHEN THERE WAS A BIG SURGE OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COMING OVER
THE BORDER.
WHETHER THERE IS ONE NOW OR NOT,
WE DON'T KNOW.
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE
PRESIDENT MEANS WHEN HE SAYS WE
WILL HAVE THE MILITARY ON THE
BORDER BUT THAT IS SOMETHING HE
IS MEETING WITH GENERAL MATTIS
ABOUT SOME OF THE DEFENSE
SECRETARY, AND THEY WILL FIGURE
IT OUT.
>> Bret: KATIE?
>> IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION ON THE BORDER.
IT'S ABOUT DETERRENCE WITH
CARTELS AND VIOLENT OPERATIONS
THAT ARE HAPPENING THERE AS
WELL.
THIS WILL PROBABLY BE WELCOMED
BY THE GOVERNORS OF ARIZONA AND
TEXAS.
IT WILL NOT BE WELCOMED BY THE
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA, TO BE
SURE.
BUT THIS DOES GO HAND-IN-HAND
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TALKING
POINTS AND PUSH THIS WEEK TO END
CATCH AND RELEASE.
TO ME, THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCING
HE WANTS A MILITARY ON THE
BORDER, WE DON'T KNOW HOW
EXACTLY LONG THAT WILL BE.
HE WANTS IT TO BE UNTIL THE THE
WHILE HIS BELT, CONSIDERING
GEORGE W. BUSH HAD THE
NATIONAL GUARD THERE FOR TWO
YEARS, PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD THEM
THERE FOR ABOUT A YEAR IN THREE
MONTHS.
IT MIGHT NOT BE FOR AS LONG AS
IT TAKES TO BUILD A WALL BECAUSE
THAT WILL TAKE LONGER, PROBABLY
THAT HAS PRESIDENCY.
HE'S CLEARLY SENDING A MESSAGE
OF DETERRENCE BY PUTTING A
MILITARY THERE WHEN HE'S TALKING
ABOUT PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM
COMING HERE BECAUSE OUR OWN
IMMIGRATION LAWS ALLOW PEOPLE
WHO GET AIR FROM CERTAIN
COUNTRIES, THE MAJORITY OF THEM,
TO STAY.
IT BECOMES MORE OF A PROBLEM FOR
OUR LEGAL SYSTEM THEN BORDERS.
>> Bret: HE TALKED ABOUT THAT,
MATTHEW, ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THESE FOLKS COME IN, THEY SEEK
ASYLUM, AND ESSENTIALLY THE
COURT SYSTEM IS OVERWHELMED.
'S 700 DAYS IS THE AVERAGE TO
GET FROM THE POINT OF THE BORDER
TO AN ACTUAL HEARING.
>> YOU CAN MAKE AN ARGUMENT THAT
IMMIGRATION POLITICS GOT
DONALD TRUMP THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINATION AND HELPED HIM WIN
BACK THE PRESIDENCY.
THIS IS A NATURAL ISSUE FOR HIM.
WHEN HE WAS INAUGURATED
PRESIDENT, THE ILLEGAL BORDER
TRAFFIC DROPPED PRECIPITOUSLY.
A LOT OF THESE MOVES ARE TO
REESTABLISH THE DETERRENCE, TO
SAY THAT WE WILL POLICE THIS
BORDER.
THERE ARE LEGISLATIVE
RESTRICTIONS ON WHAT THE
MILITARY CAN DO ONCE IT IS
DISPATCHED THERE.
THEY TYPICALLY SERVE IN AN
ADVISORY ROLE, LOGISTICAL ROLE,
TO FREE UP THE ACTUAL BORDER
PATROL.
ALL OF THIS IS HAPPENING AT THE
SAME TIME, BRET, THAT TRUMP IS
EXPLORING WAYS THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE CAN HELP FUND THE WALL
WHICH IS THE MAIN OBJECT HERE I
THINK.
>> Bret: FUNDING IS THE BIG
QUESTION.
MEANTIME, TALKING ABOUT THE
SERIOUS SITUATION, ASKING A
QUESTION ABOUT U.S. TROOPS IN
SYRIA.
>> IT'S TIME.
WE WERE VERY SUCCESSFUL AGAINST
ISIS, WE WILL BE SUCCESSFUL
AGAINST ANYBODY MILITARILY.
BUT SOMETIMES, IT'S TIME TO COME
BACK HOME.
I WANT TO GET OUT.
I WANT TO BRING OUR TROOPS BACK
ON.
I WANT TO START REBUILDING OUR
NATION.
GROUPS OF OUR PEOPLE AND GROUPS
OF OUR ALLIES.
SAUDI ARABIA IS VERY INTERESTED,
NO DECISION.
AND I SAID, WELL, YOU KNOW, YOU
WANT IS TO SAY, MAYBE YOU HAVE
TO PAY.
>> Bret: THEY WILL HAVE TO
PAY.
SAUDI ARABIA, GULF STATES.
MEANWHILE, AT THE SAME TIME,
ALMOST THE EXACT SAME TIME, THE
U.S. COUNTER GOODLATTE ENVOY WAS
SAYING THIS TO REPORTERS.
>> WE ARE IN SYRIA TO FIGHT ISIS
AND THAT IS OUR MISSION.
OUR MISSION IS NOT OVER AND WE
WILL COMPLETE THAT MISSION.
>> Bret: SO THERE IS
OBVIOUSLY -- THE PRESIDENT IS
LAYING GROUNDWORK HERE FOR
PULLING OUT OF THAT OPERATION.
WHEN IT'S DONE IT'S REALLY THE
QUESTION.
>> WHEN IT'S DONE AND IF YOU
PULL OUT TOO SOON, DO YOU CREATE
A VACUUM THAT IS FILLED BY
RUSSIA AND IRAN AND GIVES ISIS A
CHANCE TO REGROUP.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT HE RAN
AGAINST WHEN HE CRITICIZED
BARACK OBAMA FOR PUTTING A DATE
CERTAIN FOR PULLING TROOPS OUT
OF IRAQ.
HE SAID THE BAD GUYS WILL WAIT
YOU OUT.
MAN IS WHY YOU HAVE MILITARY
EXPERTS SAYING, THIS IS NOT A GO
EXPERTS SAYING, THIS IS NOT A G
EXPERTS SAYING, THIS IS NOT A GD
EXPERTS SAYING, THIS IS NOT A GA
EXPERTS SAYING, THIS IS NOT A G.
AS MUCH AS DONALD TRUMP'S
DEEPEST INSTINCTS ARE, COME
HOME, USE THAT MONEY TO REBUILD
THE NATION, HE'S KIND OF A
HAWKISH NONINTERVENTIONIST, IF
THERE IS SUCH A THING.
THIS IS GOING TO BE TOUGH FOR
HIM TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THIS.
>> Bret: THINK ABOUT THAT
SOUND BITE WE JUST LISTEN TO,
KATIE, AND HIS NEW INCOMING
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR JOHN
BOLTON, AND HOW THOSE TWO THINGS
TRACK.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY THE PRESIDENT WHO
MAKES POLICY.
BOLTON WOULD BE THE ADVISOR.
CLEARLY, HE WOULD THINK
OTHERWISE.
>> GIVING AN END DATE WITHOUT AN
ACTUAL TIME-STAMP IS COUNTER TO
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS SAID
THEY WERE DUE.
YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT JOHN BOLTON
COMING IN ABOUT THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR, IT WILL BE
VERY INTERESTING TO SEE HOW
GETTING OUT OF SYRIA, NO MATTER
WHEN THAT IS, COUPLES WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S NEW PLAN ON
IRAN.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT RELEASES
NATIONAL SECURITY STRATEGY, IRAN
WAS THE MAIN FOCUS.
IRAN WAS THE MAIN FOCUS UNDER
GENERAL McMASTER.
IT IS STILL THE MAIN FOCUS.
IT IS INTERESTING TO SEE HIM
TALKING ABOUT THE SAUDIS.
HE UNDERSTAND THEY HAVE A VESTED
INTEREST IN MAKING SURE THAT
THAT PART OF THE REGION AS IT
STABILIZED.
HE SAID ALL ALONG, OTHER
COUNTRIES WHO HAVE AN INTEREST
THERE NEED TO STEP UP.
THE SAUDI SEEM LIKE IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS, THEY ARE
WILLING TO DO THAT.
BUT IF THEY ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE TOUGH ON IRAN, AS
THEY HAVE LAID OUT IN THEIR
STRATEGIES BEFORE, SYRIA, TAKING
IT OUT OF THE PICTURE WILL BE
VERY, VERY DIFFICULT.
>> Bret: FINALLY, I WANT TO
TOUCH ON THIS OTHER ISSUE, AND
THAT IS AMAZON, WHERE THE
PRESIDENT HAS REALLY STEPPED UP
THE ATTACKS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
POST OFFICE AND THE POST OFFICE
IS LOSING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND THE TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING FOR
THAT MONEY BECAUSE IT DELIVERS
PACKAGES FOR AMAZON AT A VERY
BELOW COST AND THAT IS NOT FAIR
TO THE UNITED STATES, IT'S NOT
FAIR TO OUR TAXPAYERS, AND
AMAZON HAS THE MONEY TO PAY THE
FAIR RATE OF THE POST OFFICE,
WHICH WOULD BE MUCH MORE THAN
THEY ARE PAYING RIGHT NOW.
SO AMAZON IS GOING TO HAVE TO
PAY MUCH MORE MONEY TO THE
POST OFFICE.
>> Bret: SO MATTHEW, THIS IS
KIND OF -- WELL, IT IS,
UNPRECEDENTED FOR A PRESIDENT TO
GO AFTER ONE COMPANY WITH TWEETS
AND STATEMENTS.
THE POST OFFICE DOESN'T OPERATE
ON TAXPAYER MONEY.
IT IS A PAID FOR SERVICE.
THEY OPERATE IN BUILDINGS AND
FACILITIES THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO PAY TAXES ON.
BUT WHAT ABOUT HOW THE PRESIDENT
IS DESCRIBING ALL OF THOSE?
>> AMAZON IN THE POST OFFICE TO
HAVE SOME TYPE OF SPECIAL
CONTRACT BUT NO ONE REALLY KNOWS
THE DETAILS OF IT.
I DO NOTICE IS A FREQUENT BUYER
OF BOOKS, BOTH FROM AMAZON
PROPER AND FROM USED BOOKSTORES,
THAT RETAIL AND AMAZON, I FIND
THE AMAZON PACKAGES GET THERE
MUCH MORE QUICKLY THAN THE ONES
THAT HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
REGULAR POST OFFICE CHANNEL.
DONALD TRUMP IS A POPULIST
FIGURE.
>> Bret: THAT'S INTERESTING.
WE'LL DO A STUDY.
>> ONE ANNA GOODHOPE PIECE OF IT
EVIDENCE, -- PEOPLE TEND TO
VIEW THIS IN TERMS OF TRUMP'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH AMAZON'S CEO,
JEFF BEZOS.
ONE STREAM OF COMMUNICATION IS
GETTING US FROM ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMERCIAL
REAL ESTATE BUSINESS AND
INDUSTRY, WHO HAVE BEEN HARD-HIT
BY THE CHANGING NATURE OF THE
RETAIL ECONOMY.
DONALD TRUMP TENDS TO THINK IN
TERMS OF TANGIBLE OBJECTS.
SO I THINK WHAT IS BOTHERING HIM
HERE, AMONG MANY OTHER THINGS,
IS THE SENSE THAT OUR ECONOMY IS
A SHIFTING IN WAY THAT HIS
FRIENDS WHO DEAL IN SMALL RETAIL
BUSINESSES OR COMMERCIAL
PROPERTIES LIKE MALLS ARE LOSING
OUT TO THIS MAJOR INTERNET
GIANTS.
>> Bret: LET'S JUST SAY IF HE
WOKE UP TOMORROW AND SAID,
WALMART IS TAKING OUT
MOM-AND-POP STORES, TOO.
>> TWO THINGS GOING ON.
ONE, THERE IS A LOT OF RETAIL
AND TRUMP TOWERS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
HE IS PROBABLY SUFFERING ALONG
WITH EVERYBODY ELSE.
BUT THE IDEA THAT THE PRESIDENT
OF UNITED STATES WOULD GO AFTER
AN INDIVIDUAL COMPANY, WHY ISN'T
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE --
>> Bret: THEY PUT OUT A
STATEMENT.
SPEAK ABOUT ISN'T THE ENTIRE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, WHO WAS
ABSOLUTELY --
>> OBAMA WENT OVER COKE
INDUSTRIES PRETTY SPECIFICALLY.
IT'S NOT TOTALLY UNPRECEDENTED.
>> THAT WAS EGREGIOUS AND
RIGHTLY CALLED OUT.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY AND --
>> Bret: LAST WORD.
>> KEEP IN MIND, THEY WERE
GOVERNMENT WORKERS WHO
NEGOTIATED THIS CONTRACT.
SO WHAT IS THE STATUS OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY FOR AMAZON
GETTING A SUPPOSE A DEAL THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS TALKING ABOUT?
>> WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY GOT A
DEAL.
>> Bret: WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE DEAL IS.
ALL WE KNOW IS THAT SOMETHING IS
HAPPENING.
>> THE POST OFFICE HAS TO CHARGE
TO COVER HIS COSTS.
I DON'T THINK THE POST OFFICE IS
ALLOWED TO GIVE A CUT RATE DEAL.
>> WE ALL KNOW THE GOVERNMENT IS